[Applause]
oh come
on
four
[Applause]
oh oh
oh good save off thanks thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
good
oh no
way we got it who
[Applause]
one oh oh
what that was a
roller
[Music]
[Applause]
oh you really have to work with the hips
on that
one
[Applause]
and 81% of you guys watching haven't
subscribed so help us out and subscribe
now oh first
try nice
no
[Applause]
Bas
W that was the craziest R ever it just
kept
[Applause]
going it Wass
perfectly you can actually attack with
it
it's a
roller it took
even yes come
on
yes
what
[Music]
no okay
oh
oh let go let go
[Applause]
Go
Boom come
on come
on
[Applause]
burning
oh oh
[Applause]
oh oh oh W oh get
him
one
two
three let's
[Applause]
go oh no is that your phone it's my
phone
oh oh no how do I missed
that
oh
yeah oh how did you have
it three 4 6 8
[Music]
woo
we
[Applause]
oh
hey
[Applause]
wo
you go get it you go get
[Applause]
it oh five complete
layers
Oh wrong target
sorry that's it that's it that's the
[Applause]
one
nice oh
oh that's incredible you actually went
my
[Applause]
side that's it
[Music]
w
help us get to 5 million and hit
subsscribe
oh thought